There are times when the data isn't available and
you need to collect your own. Now, when talking
about the various methods that can be used,
there are a few factors that distinguish them.
For instance, there's the level of intervention.
Is it observational, which is strictly hands off,
or is it experimental, where you get in the mix
and you create a situation? What kind of data
type do you have? Is it quantitative, or numerical
data, which is what we often use in data science?
Or, is it qualitative, specifically text, which
can be analyzed but requires different approaches?
And how about the location? Is it online or
is it in person? All of these combinations can
be used to gather data that you need,
if you're careful about your design.
For instance, let's look at interviews.
These are ideal for new topics or audiences.
They can be structured or unstructured. However,
interviews are generally very time-consuming, and
they may require a very specialized training. This
is one of the situations where you actually may
want to hire an anthropologist or a sociologist
to come in and conduct the research for you.
Next, surveys. They can be open-ended or
closed-ended. They're very easy to administer
online to a lot of people. But, you need to watch
out for wording and sampling bias in order to get
the information that's gonna be really most useful
in helping you reach your goals in your project.
Next is card sorting. This is where participants
sort topics that are written on different cards.
Card sorting is useful for determining
categories and hierarchies.
It's also a great way to check
the usability of a web site.
You can actually do different kinds of card
sorting in terms of an exploratory one to
find out how you should do it and another kind
to see how well your proposed solution works.
Next, how about experiments? This
is where you have a manipulation.
That's where you get involved, and you
cause a situation to be different for
one group of people or another. Some people
freak out about the word "manipulation",
and think it's about coercion or mind control. It
simply means about creating different conditions.
And it is generally considered the best
method for cause-and-effect inferences.
On the other hand, in most situations,
experimentation can be labor-intensive
and can require very extensive specialized
training. There is one major exception to this,
and that's A/B testing, which is used on web
pages where you have two versions of a web page
or an element on a web page, and it's randomly
assigned, one version or another, to viewers.
In summary, to start a data science project,
you’ll first get exactly the data that you need.
If what it doesn't exist, you will have
to collect the new data. Many of these
methods may require in-depth training, and
you may want to hire consultants for them.
Also, there are important ethical
issues when conducting research,
especially when it's live and in person.
You'll want to consult an expert about those.